in Florida President Trump made his
first public appearance of his holiday
vacation thanking local firefighters and
promoting his own record in office the
evidence shows the president went a
little too far with one assertion chip
Reid is traveling with him in West Palm
Beach Florida chip good morning good
morning that is not the first time the
president has claimed that he signed
more bills into law than any modern
president since Truman and according to
a CBS news analysis President Trump has
signed more than 90 bills but that is
hundreds fewer than the nearly 700
pieces of legislation that one bill
tracking website counts for President
Kennedy in the same amount of time and
not half as many as the more than 200
bills signed by presidents Clinton and
George HW Bush during the same period
President Trump is correct though that
the stock market has improved during his
presidency and he has kept his pledge to
cut regulations but he can't turn that
quote big big beautiful ship around
alone he needs Congress to that end in
early January he'll be meeting with
House Speaker Paul Ryan and Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell at the
presidential retreat of Camp David to
start strategizing for 2018 viana chip
thank you